really the only solution that we have to
congested on the strip
soon more of elon musk tunnels will be
built under las vegas and good evening
to you thanks for joining us at six i'm
brian loftis and i'm denise valdez so
those new tunnels are going to connect
out to the airport over to allegiant
stadium along with a bunch of hotels
county commissioners gave the plan the
okay today joe moeller is live outside
the convention center where the loop is
already in operation at this point with
more project details joe
brian the goal is to get the cars off of
the las vegas strip and get them
underground the cars we're talking about
are teslas of course here's a live look
at the west station you can see all
these teslas parked outside they're
about to go underground and take people
to different halls here at the las vegas
convention center now the boring company
wants to take people all over las vegas
we all know how busy the strip can get
the boring company's solution to put
more cars underground this entire
project could cost anywhere from 500
million dollars to a billion dollars
please cast your vote and that motion
passes wednesday county commissioners
approved the boring company's plans to
expand the vegas loop to a total of 29
miles there's going to be a lot of dirt
so make sure you don't destroy the roads
in the process absolutely that'd be
honest here is the proposed map it has
51 stops including downtown at strip
hotels allegion stadium and the airport
the boring company and elon will finance
the cost of the tunnels
and the properties have agreed that they
will pay for the cost of their stations
lvcba ceo steve hill says the vote
allows the boring company to access the
right of way underground and the
franchise agreement that was approved
details the boring company's
responsibilities he says this is a
one-of-a-kind project that will help get
more people around vegas quicker there
will be a fair charge
it will be per car and not per rider
and the boring company is committed that
that will be somewhere between bus fare
and what it would cost
to ride on an uber or a left the project
will take a few years next the company
will have to pull building permits
teslas will be driven underground at
first but the goal is to go driverless
it just makes vegas more attractive
back out here live you're taking a live
look at resorts world because that is
where the next tunnel is already under
construction actually it's being built
right now and hill expects that to be in
operation early next year as far as how
long this whole entire project would
take get underway they're expecting it
to start in about six months to a year
reporting live outside the las vegas
convention center joe moller live local
now